bonsoir nous sommes mercredi 16 décembre
merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition de 7,8 le journal comme
chaque jour votre actualité locale
entouré des journalistes de la rédaction
mais aussi de nos invités
on commence tout de suite avec les
titres de cette édition la chambre de
commerce et d'industrie de versailles
yvelines a participé hier et aujourd'hui
à la 16e édition du challenge écho
l'entrepreneur deux jours de formation
pour une initiative qui valorise
l'entrepreneuriat auprès des jeunes
rives et noir l'épisode 7 de la saga
star wars arrive enfin sur les écrans à
saint quentin en yvelines les fans
étaient au rendez vous
retour sur le phénomène de la guerre des
étoiles événement phare de cette fin
d'année siens et le concours du meilleur
apprenti de france au nord les jeunes
apprentis futurs grands chefs de demain
cette année le vainqueur de la
compétition et vit six mois et s'appelle
wendat le brillant apprentis au
restaurant la ferme deux voisins il est
en plateau ce soir avec nous a
accompagné de romain gicquel le chef
d'établissement
ils reviendront avec nous sur cette
compétition et cette belle récompense et
un mode économie pour commencer hier
mardi 15 décembre et aujourd'hui
mercredi
las la chambre de commerce d'industrie
de versailles yvelines à participer à la
16ème édition du challenge écoles
entrepreneurs cette initiative permet de
valoriser l'entrepreneuriat auprès des
jeunes yvelinois cette année deux
classes de bts de l'école supérieure des
systèmes de management de rambouillet
ont participé à ces deux jours de
formation
le reportage est signé fanny bourdillat
les dents
ce mardi les étudiants en bts
comptabilité gestion à rambouillet il
découvre le goût d'entreprendre à la
chambre de commerce de versailles
venu avec huit projets de création
d'entreprises ces jeunes vont pouvoir
participer à la 16ème édition du
challenge écoles entrepreneurs le but
est bien sûr comme tous les ans de faire
participer nos jeunes de bts de les
cimes
un challenge qui est un challenge de
création d'entreprise et nous avons
souhaité cette année en modifier
l'expérience et les faire travailler
hors les murs de l'école
le produit de luxe des saunas et hammams
de luxe c'est le projet d'entreprise de
nicolas avec son groupe il étudie leur
business plan
l'occasion de concrétiser leur envie
d'entreprendre aujourd'hui on fait on va
apprendre à surtout pouvoir se
restructurer parce qu'en fait on a des
idées plus ou moins vagues et donc ces
deux jours de formation vont nous
permettre de vraiment rentrer dans le
vif du sujet pour la cci des yvelines
cette initiative permet surtout
d'insuffler l'idée d'entreprendre auprès
des jeunes du département
il est extrêmement important de de
donner l'envié d'entreprendre que ce
soit autour de la création d'entreprise
mais également pour sa vie
professionnelle de façon générale on
attend que les jeunes s'investissent
dans leur travail qui soit force de
proposition voilà et autour de la
création d'entreprise mais bien sûr on a
besoin de beaucoup de deux envie
d'entreprendre
actuellement 25 % des entrepreneurs
français ont moins de 30 ans un chiffre
qui a triplé en dix ans économie et
sports à présent le rugby-club de
versailles a lancé aujourd'hui une
campagne de financement participatif de
150 jeunes membres du club ont c'est une
marche du stade de porchefontaine
jusqu'à la place de la mairie à
versailles l'objectif récolter 5000
euros afin d'améliorer les conditions du
club on a un pool de jeunes qui est très
fort à versailles entre les u 6 et u 20
on a quatre cent vingt jeunes donc avec
une école de rugby qui fait 250 enfants
100-120 cadets et juniors et 50 du 20
mai la sq a donc dans les yvelines on
est le premier
au niveau du pôle jeunes et on a aussi
un développement notre expertise qui est
fort et on veut fortifier ce pool jeunes
et pour ça on fait appel à une de
financement participatif puisque toute
façon nous avons des partenaires mais
les partenaires
ils font ce qu'ils peuvent on est ravi
de les avoir mais il nous faut plus et
on s'est dit que stimuler la web lundi
les internautes c'était peut-être une
possibilité pour nous d'atteindre notre
objectif
à noter qu'un flash mob sera également
organisé le 10 janvier sur la place du
marché de versailles pour appeler à un
maximum de dons vous avez jusqu'au mois
de février pour participer et les aider
dans leurs aventures et enfin c'est
l'événement du jour le septième volet de
star wars et rêvait de la force est
sorti ce mercredi dans les salles
obscures record de pré vente en france
produits dérivés beaucourt sur
l'engouement autour de ce long métrage
unique l ennemi d'euros et jérémy
quesada sont allés à la rencontre des
fans de la première heure à 50 en hiver
il faudrait avoir passé des mois dans
une galaxie lointaine très lointaine
pour ignorer l'arrivée du nouveau star
wars sur les écrans français ce mercredi
à l'ugc de 50 ans ni ville une centaine
de padawan a pris d'assaut les salles
obscures
ça représente beaucoup de souvenirs
parce que j'ai été voir le premier avec
mon père en 77 je crois ou
quelque chose dans le genre donc c'est
beaucoup de souvenirs qui n'est pas fan
de star wars j'ai envie de dire sans
même un peu plein des yeux quoi je suis
content ça fait dix ans que j'attends le
septième volet de la saga pulvérise déjà
tous les records 500 mille places ont
été vendues sur le territoire français
avant sa sortie dans ce cinéma saint
quentinois 2650 billets ont été pré
commander sur internet pour ce mercredi
c'est du jamais vu on n'a jamais mis un
film à la vente aussi longtemps à
l'avancé ce qu'il faut savoir qu'on l'a
mis fin octobre à la vente
les gens pouvaient réserver pouvez
acheter leurs places sur la semaine on
est à cinq milles
on va dire 900 places donc pareil hein
c'est un record battu pour l'instant
c'est un droit c'est également un
business en dehors des salles depuis
l'été dernier les produits dérivés ont
envahi les rayons de supermarchés dans
le magasin la grande récré de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines de jouets
achetés sur trois sont estampillés star
wars
nous avons reçu des visites des curieux
cette semaine échantillonnés qui
regardaient qui attendaient impatiemment
qui attendait les nouveautés et ça
continue on jette de si en plus ça va
être en rupture de stock apparemment
pour noël donc on en profite c'est la
dernière boîte à une semaine de noël la
star wars magna n'est pas prête de
s'arrêter et ce ne sont pas les
nouvelles générations qui vous le
contredire et en plateau ce soir avec
nous le meilleur apprenti de france 2015
bonsoir gwendal brillant alors vous êtes
accompagné de romain g t elle vous fera
vous aussi vous êtes le chef du
restaurant la ferme de voisins et
gwendal également votre apprenti alors
tout d'abord madalle félicitations si
pauvres voilà votre concours vous
attendiez couronné meilleur apprenti de
france
j'ai tout fait pour pour l'autre alors
comment ça c'est comme ça c'est un petit
peu passé j'ai passé trois étapes une
qui sait pour l'île de france
après la demi-finale où on était 24
candidats qui s'étaient pour toute la
fois je les fait à bordeaux et ensuite
la finale affirme andy paris m'ont été
dit que c'est une très grande fierté
c'est l'aboutissement de
de la formation que nous dispensons à la
ferme de voisins et de la transmission
que nous fêtons donner aux jeunes jeunes
générations tourner un reportage
meilleur apprenti de france
c'est assez assidus on peut dire c'est
ça je mens je m'entraînais presque tous
les jours matin et soir avec mouche
effet et mon employeur et mon chef de
bouche à délivrer des plages
je répétais répéter chaque jour 11 et
certaines modifications suivantes jeu
suivant les résultats suivants la vie
déchets suivants tout ça et après hong
kong ou t on
on a un peu suivi à un système
d'entraînement de sportifs tout
simplement à répéter certaines actions
certaines recettes et une fois qu'on
était au point on essaie de les mettre
bout à bout deux les descentes je vais
traîner une entre les autres pour
pouvoir rentrer dans les temps
exactement
alors pour descendre en tout cas le cd
sans mon entrée je réalisais ils ne
nagent de saint jacques avec un pavé de
saumon mi-cuit au riesling les images
voilà c'est ça voilà leur délicieux et
donc ses nombreuses s de carotte et
céleri sur un lit de
d'une fondue de poireaux c'est la nage
de saint jacques ory slim un pavé de son
écuyer des saint-jacques d'accord et
c'est un plat qui va me compliquez pas
nettoyé compliqué à réaliser
voici une entrée sur laquelle on a
travaillé sur le taillage des légumes
surtout sur l'assaisonnement sur la
cuisson du saumon et puis après ma vous
aviez un temps imparti pour ajustements
réalisés
j'avais quatre heures pour réaliser
l'entrée le plat il détient d'accord à
ce que ça se rapproche un petit peu des
émissions culinaires que l'on peut voir
à la télé arrive au point spécialement
parce que nous c'est nous qui faisons
tout le travail
et puis hein il ya un travail auparavant
donc sur les émissions culinaires en
général c'est un panier qui découvre sur
mike hayes est d'accord avec cela on est
sur quelque chose de très professionnel
on n'est pas sûr de la téléréalité au
son du jeu télévisuel
si je puis dire c'est quelque chose qui
est jugé par des professionnels pas par
des téléspectateurs donc des gens du
métier qui connaissent bien la cuisine
très bien la cuisine en a des très beaux
jury donc voilà c'est déjà fait
toilettes est jugée juste nettoyées déjà
failli envoyer devant des chefs maître
écuyer de france à la voile
on avait une vingtaine de chefs qui
jugeait les dix les dix apprentis qui
était en finale
le titre de meilleur apprenti de france
peut se comparer à celui de meilleur
ouvrier de france un peu le le titre
avant on va dire la ceinture rouge avant
la ceinture noire faut savoir que
beaucoup de meilleur apprenti de france
dans ses meilleures audiences ont été
par la suite meilleur ouvrier de france
c'est un petit peu un petit peu dans le
même style mais c'est eux c'est déjà un
très bon résultat de mai revêtement
c'est beaucoup plus de travail c'est
encore plus dur et à les épreuves donc
justement été assez compliqué vous devez
faire également un plat et un dessert
c'est ça en 4h01 4h30 que les ombres
alors justement crois qu'on a également
ici les images justement des plats que
vous avez peut-être nous commentée en
plateau
alors ça c'est quoi exactement ça c'est
un carré de porc poulet et avec j'ai
servi une charlotte de chou rouge pomme
marron et indique une aile de fromage
woods est est-ce que ça on pourra parler
reparler on veut retrouver au restaurant
ah oui ce serait bien de pâques on
pourra retrouver il ya quelques années
on travaille déjà sur le cas de cochon
francina un peu comme celui ci mais on
mon travail est de fumée vous êtes tout
jeune c'est habituel comme d'avoir des
apprentis ou six jeunes à qui arrivent à
réussir ce genre de plat alors habituel
non sonder tous les jeunes qui disques
sélectionnés là pour ce concours est
pour la finale avait un très bon niveau
sont des jeunes qui sont passionnés qui
sont investis dans leur travail qu'on a
envie de réussir sa métier qui est très
compliqué il faut beaucoup
d'investissement personnel et n'a mis
suffisamment d'investissements pour
réussir le titre maintenant ça
représente quoi pour vous ça va être
pour votre futur vous allez rester du
coup restaurant la ferme de voisin
qu'est ce que ça va vous apporter
et pour moi ma mois déjà c'est une
fierté pour moi même et pour mais pour
mes proches pour mes chefs pour tout ça
et après ça dépend de ce que je ferai au
mois de septembre soit je vais
travailler directement dans certaines
maisons que j'aimerais et côtoyer sinon
je ferais un an ou deux ans aux
pâtisseries l'été le titre vraiment vous
permet voilà d'aléas prêts à travailler
dans les plus grandes maisons ont des
plus grands restaurants ont déjà accepté
directement ça c'est ça ça vaut pas mal
de portes
pas de nous en tant que professionnel
ses tresses et beaucoup de
reconnaissance c'est très agréable pour
nous ça une fois de plus à montpellier
soir quand ils vont se bousculer pour
venir chez vous peut-être peut-être pas
je ne sais pas on a déjà pas mal
d'apprentis mais en tout cas c'est une
belle reconnaissance pour nous aussi
bien au niveau des des apprentis qu'au
niveau des professionnels qui du coup
quand on a peu parlé nous ils voient un
petit peu le type de formation qui nous
donnons maintenant ça va lui ouvre pas
mal de portes effectivement mais ça
n'empêche pas qu'il va continuer à
travailler dur parce que pour le reste
ans a permis une clientèle il ya des
gens qui suivent je sais pas si ça
amènera une pureté de poules restaurant
mais bon nous notre objectif était
atteint c'est d'amener le plus haut
possible on a réussi maintenant il sera
avec nous jusqu'à fin juillet pour finir
son apprentissage et puis après il
valait il va s'envoler un petit peu et
dont vous parlez de pâtisserie est ce
que vous allez participer à d'autres
concours ça vous a donné envie d'aller
plus loin nos sur d'autres concours il
ya aussi des concours voilà meilleur
apprenti pâtissier ou
championnat de france de pâtisserie où
il a plusieurs concours comme on parle
souvent voilà de l'apprentissage c'est
une thématique qui est son blog le
gouvernement encourage les jeunes à y
aller moi c'est un bel exemple de
réussite mais c'est quand même compliqué
je pense d'être apprentis ce temps dans
la restauration scam kick ass est
difficile il faut le dire bien sûr c'est
quand on aime le métier n'a pas de
limites la restauration j'ai dit souvent
ce sont des métiers passion quand on
aime on compte pas faut pas trop compter
les heures qu'on y passe et qu'on y met
par contre ça rend beaucoup sa superbe
ascenseur social parce que ça peut faire
évoluer des jeunes qu'on peut forcément
envie de travailler à l'école n'ont pas
les capacités à l'école ça un jeune qui
est motivé qu'à l'envi on trouve un bon
formateur peut évoluer aller assez haut
et parce que y'a peut-être pas assez de
jeunes qui se dirigent la réponse à
jacques les deux suspects dans les
écoles ya peu passé donc vont la tuer
c'est possible c'est possible que la pub
soit pas toujours très bonne foi les
apprentissages que les gens aient une
mauvaise image de l'apprentissage par
contre c'est une voix une voix très très
bonne pour la réussite qu'un on commence
à pratiquer son métier ont commencé à
acquérir de l'expérience des 15 ans dès
16 ans dès 17 ans quand on entend quand
il est bien merci beaucoup monsieur
encore félicitations au rwanda voilà on
souhaite à un beau parcours pour la
suite que nous suivrons et à présent je
vous propose de vous présenter un jeune
sportif alors c'est un golfeur il est
originaire de montigny le bretonneux et
il pourrait devenir numéro 1 français
dans quelques années bazerbes pages à
main jaya vient de passer golfeur
professionnel il participera au pro bowl
pour la 3e division européenne en 2016
mais qu'elle elle me d'euros et patrick
jacq de l'iss nous ont fait son portrait
et ils ont rencontré regarder le futur
tiger woods est peut-être ini montrent
un benjamin jahier tout juste 22 ans
vient d'intégrer le circuit
professionnel
le golfeur qui a débuté sur les greens
suit un stage organisé en 2008 par la
mairie de montigny-le-bretonneux
évoluera l'année prochaine dans le pro
gold tours l'équivalent de la troisième
division
depuis que j'ai démarré golf ça a été
voilà cette idée là 2
de se préparer en vue un jour peut-être
de jouer sur le circuit pro et
aujourd'hui c'est la première étape
voilà donc trois circuits satellite
allemand la 3e division européenne pour
peut-être dans quatre cinq ans être dans
l'élite mondiale du golf pas du mois
c'est l'objectif qui essaie depuis de
budget des marelles golf en tout cas ce
golfeur a connu une ascension fulgurante
et atypique en sept ans benjamin est
passé du statut d'amateur à celui de
professionnel sportif évinois est
notamment devenu champion de france par
équipes avec les moins de 17 en 2009
une réussite qu'il doit notamment à son
jeu long c'est vrai qu'il a été reconnu
par plusieurs pros qu'ils ont fait
travailler qu'il a une grosse vitesse de
swing et une frappe assez conséquente
voilà qu'il faut lui permettre
d'atteindre le meilleur niveau j'ai la
chance de pouvoir frapper assez fort la
balle est relativement droit donc si
vous permet même si les parcours sont
longs 2 à mettre trop en difficulté
après quelques petits soucis au niveau
du petit jeu mais c'est pour ça que
voilà on s'entraîne pour jour et qu'on
travaille sur ces points sur ses points
faibles
un jeu court que lenny montrent un
devrait améliorer pour se rapprocher du
niveau de ses idoles le grand classique
tiger woods a quand même inspiré
beaucoup de golfeurs et puis qu'il reste
le meilleur golfeur au monde là qu'on
s'en vient jour d'arrivée à ceux à ce
niveau là quoi on aspire tous à ça être
être nouveau rang mondial après pour la
patience du travail et prendre sa chance
quand quand on peut l'apprendre et et
avancer benjamin juillet reprendra la
compétition au mois de mars il devrait
s'aligner sur un tournoi marocain
il ya tout juste un an le point services
aux particuliers de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines signé un
partenariat avec edf pour lutter contre
la précarité énergétique sur
l'agglomération
ce partenariat a permis la création d'un
poste d'ambassadeur de l'efficacité
énergétique
nous allons nous y intéresser ce soir
avec mes amis poté bonsoir mélanie
sponsors florennes le poste
d'ambassadeur de l'efficacité
énergétique et une volonté de l'état
annoncée en mars 2013 par le président
de la république françois hollande
l'objectif du plan de rénovation
énergétique et de réaliser
d'ici 2020 une économie des
consommations d'énergie de 38 %
ici le poste a été créé il ya un an vous
l'avez dit floral lors de la signature
d'un partenariat entre la communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines le point
services aux particuliers
le psp et erdf le psp travail sur la
précarité énergétique qui entraîne des
impayés
sébastien le goff en est le directeur il
nous explique la complémentarité de sa
structure et de l'ambassadeur
c'est un soutien oui il vient compléter
en fait le dispositif pôle énergie
dupont services aux particuliers
vraiment tout simplement dont il a été
rattaché au pôle énergie l'ambassadeur
nommé fica sites énergétiques y connaît
aussi bien le programme habiter mieux
que les problématiques d'un payé
puisqu'il peut être aussi amené à
rencontrer des habitants et des
propriétaires occupants qui du coup sont
pas éligibles au programme habiter mieux
mais qui on rencontre toutes mènent des
problématiques d'impayés d'électricité
ou de gaz
alors les postes sont des emplois
d'avenir qui s'adresse à des jeunes de
16 à 25 ans l'ambassadeur sur saint
quentin en yvelines a été recruté au
mois de février il a été formé par la
lèque l' agence locale de l'énergie et
du climat de l'agglomération mais quel
est son rôle précisément à la nier le
rôle de l'ambassadeur c'est d'identifier
les ménages en situation de précarité
énergétique
d'où sa présence au point services aux
particuliers la question de la
rénovation n'est pas toujours facile à
appréhender notamment pour les ménages
les plus précaires
une fois identifié l'ambassadeur est là
pour les accompagner dans les démarches
à voir si le projet est éligible au
programme à nous habiter mieux notamment
et a monté un dossier
écoutez guirec de la porte c'est
l'ambassadeur sur saint quentin en
yvelines
il ya beaucoup de personnes qui sont
éligible donc qui regroupe vraiment tous
les critères pour bénéficier des aides
du programme habiter mieux mais qui sont
pas au courant donc qu'ils vont faire
leurs travaux de leur côté sans pour
autant bénéficier des aides auxquelles
ils ont tout à fait le droit
alors oui c'est vrai qu'il faut monter
le dossier des fois ça peut prendre du
temps mais à côté les aides qu importe
habiter mieux sont pas négligeables
alors on l'a entendu dire est que de la
porte par le dead ce sont des aides
financières des crédits d'impôts dans ça
dépend surtout des ressources les aides
peut monter jusqu'à 80 % des dépenses
engagées
lana subventionne de 35 à 50 % d'un
montant de travaux plafonné à 20 mille
euros il est aussi une aide habiter
mieux elle est forfaitaire entre ce 1600
euros et 2000 là aussi versé par l'anah
la région et vos communes peuvent aussi
vous aider mais il ya là des critères à
rassembler et c'est direct de la porte
qui ne les explique pas quelques points
pour bénéficier de ces aides comme j'ai
dit notamment être propriétaire il faut
que l'appartement ou la maison et plus
de 15 ans que ce soit des rénovations
basé sur les l'énergie le gaz 20
l'énergie en globalité que l'entreprise
soit enfin c'est obligatoire m'ont fait
par une entreprise agréée connell de
l'environnement il ne faut pas avoir eu
de prêt à taux zéro et il faut que ça
at-elle 25% de près novation énergétique
alors depuis le mois de septembre
l'ambassadeur de l'énergie at il
rencontré beaucoup de saint quentinois
en l'espace de quatre mois eric
delaporte a rencontré une quinzaine de
foyers il tient des permanences au psp
dont qui est située à trappes
mais aussi au centre social de magny les
hameaux et ne reçoit pas que des saint
quentinois parce que dans ces quinze
foyers flandre il ya des ménés loi à
l'heure actuelle sept foyers sont
éligibles au programme habiter mieux et
leur dossier est en cours d'évaluation
alors l'ambassadeur de l'efficacité
énergétique et donc avant tout destiné à
aider et accompagner les ménages les
plus précaires
mais la rénovation énergétique s'adresse
bien à tout le monde comment faire
comment se renseigner si l'on souhaite
faire baisser également ses factures
d'énergie alors les acteurs autour de la
rénovation énergétique sont nombreux on
peut déjà commencer à trouver des
informations sur internet
il ya notamment le site du gouvernement
et l' agence nationale de l'habitat
l'ana a créé un site spécialisé autour
de son programme habiter mieux merci
beaucoup
mélanie à présent un mot de culture hier
soir avait lieu l'inauguration des
médailles du roi à la librairie des
princes du château de versailles un
partenariat entre la maison arthus
bertrand et le château de versailles
pour présenter une collection de dix
sept médailles inspiré des collections
d'époque l'occasion de créer quelques
ressources pour le château tout en
participant au développement de cette
entreprise du patrimoine
sephora namani et patrick jacques de
dixmude du sésame pour entrer dans les
jardins du trianon sous marie antoinette
aux décorations officielles des jeux
olympiques
les médailles ont toujours été des
témoignages de l'histoire frappé
poinçonnet doré et patiné les médailles
harbour différentes fonctions depuis
l'antiquité
ma médaille avait plusieurs symboles
s'est fait dire d'abord c'était une
manière assurée de pouvoir retransmettre
son image à la postérité parce que
c'était de préférence un matériau
inaltérable ensuite la médaille pouvait
être un outil de propagande
à partir du moment où vous mettez en
avant victoire votre famille et c'est
également donc outil de propagande
complémentaires sachant que les
médailles notamment les médailles en or
servait de cadeaux diplomatiques
louis xiv fervent collectionneur de
médailles pour glorifier son règne avait
même aménagé son cabinet des médailles
au château de versailles en 1684 celui
ci aujourd'hui disparu le château a eu
l'idée de s'associer à la maison arthus
bertrand pour lancer une collection de
17 pièces hier avait lu dans la
librairie des princes du château
l'inauguration de cette collection nous
on est passionné de médailles on avait
depuis longtemps lui toute la
littérature autour du cabinet des
médailles du roi louis xiv est un grand
collectionneur et on est attaché à cet
art de la médaille on avait proposé au
château de versailles de reproduire pour
le château des médailles et déjà
anciennes ou existantes dans les fonds
du château est en aussi en inventer on
essaie de faire en centres avec le
château on puisse
résumé un peu étrange et puis avoir
quelques ressources complémentaires
l'idée c'était justement de reprendre
des médailles et puis des commercialisé
au j'avais dans tous les lieux
historiques des petites médailles à
vendre pas cher n'est pas forcément de
très bonne qualité et sans forcément un
grand lien historique un moyen de créer
des ressources pour entretenir le
château de versailles tout en
développant l'économie des entreprises
du patrimoine tels que la maison
arthus-bertrand des maisons qui sont
toutes les commandes de restauration
serait amené à péricliter et c'est à
présent la fin de cette édition merci de
nous avoir suivis tout de suite vous
avez rendez vous avec sephora namani
pour une nouvelle édition de jazz que
votre magazine culturel quant à moi je
vous retrouve demain pour le journal je
vous souhaite une bonne soirée et vous
laisse sur ce petit clin d'oeil de toute
la rédaction au nouvel épisode de la
saga star wars
réalisé par michael jarry la force est
aussi sur téléfoot 78
mon soirée merci de vous retrouver pour
cette nouvelle édition du journal
galactique tout de suite les titres de
cette édition
alors que mardi matin une tête de bull
cannes c'était découverte dans le
village de side nous recevons ce soir
jar jar binks et nous dira comment la
population réagit et évoquera avec nous
les inquiétudes qu'elle éprouve
politique à présent palpatine profite de
sa nouvelle position de chancelier
suprême de la république pour acquérir
l'approbation d'une grande partie de
l'opinion publique galactique
il a pour objectif de créer un mouvement
séparatiste au sein de la république
ainsi que d'une grande armée de la
république
il est soupçonné de vouloir créer une
armée de clones nous y reviendrons et
enfin dans notre chronique comment
maîtriser la force pour recevront ce
soir un chevalier et son jeune padawan
rester avec nous le champ d'énergie
n'aura plus de secrets pour vous
vous conférez fois
ce